how's it going everybody awesome news
today we got brand new leaked concept
art for Avengers for the pictures are
awesome and they reveal a little bit
more about some of the characters and
give us a different look at some of them
as well real quick just a heads up about
the giveaway if you would like to enter
to win a copy of Avengers infinity war
on blu-ray
a special edition poster and some
special edition memorabilia from our
partners at silk and cotton all you have
to do is subscribe to my channel like
this video and comment below with your
thoughts
and your favorite superhero okay so
let's start it off with war machine I
just did a video yesterday on how he's
getting some upgrades in the next movie
so as you can see here it's very clear
that his suit has gotten an upgrade he's
a lot bigger he's got a lot more size to
him and it looks like he's got some new
weapons on his arms and the gun that's
mounted to his shoulder is usually a
Gatling gun this doesn't look like a
Gatling gun this looks like some sort of
energy weapon so it looks like he's
gonna be bringing the heat in Avengers 4
next up is Captain America and as you
can see here he is wearing his scale
armor this uniform resembles the one
that he wore in infinity war but he has
his star back he has the scales on his
chest and his arms and the white and red
are returned to the outfit so this is a
clear statement that Captain America is
back Steve Rogers has once again taken
the mantle of Captain America he's
wearing the star again he's no longer
doing the Secret Avengers missions he's
come back and is now once again
Captain America then we have Thor who
hasn't really changed much he still has
Stormbreaker he's still wearing the same
outfit that he was wearing in infinity
war but this makes sense because he
didn't get these until basically the end
of infinity war so it makes sense that
he pretty much looks the same then we
have Iron Man and yes the pictures are
blurred and very pixelated but from what
we can tell this does look like the mark
85 armor this is interesting because an
infinity war he had the Nano
tech armor so this is interesting I'm
wondering if his nanotech will simply
take the shape of the mark 85 armor or
will he design another piece of armor
then we have this next photo which shows
Captain Marvel and Thanos now nothing's
really changed from Captain Marvel
except for her hair and it looks like
they're just trying to get different
angles and that's because these pictures
are leaked from someone who works for a
toy company so with Captain Marvel it
looks like it's really just the hair
that's changed but let's take a look at
vanna's so again he has his sword and in
one of these photos that actually looks
like he's carrying two swords we know
that the sword was supposed to be in
Avengers infinity war probably just got
cut but it does seem like it'll make an
appearance in Avengers 4 and he's also
wearing his full armor at which we
barely saw an infinity war so I hope we
get more of the armor and the sword and
Avengers 4 then we have Scarlett
Johansson and really the only change
that I see here is her hair is back to
red now the pixelation and the
blurriness and the back could be to hide
some sort of weapon but it's really hard
to tell from this photo either way I'm
super glad she has her red hair back so
last but certainly not least this
actually excited me most to see is
Hawkeye slash Ronan if you still had
some sort of doubt that Hawkeye will
become Ronan in Avengers 4 throw it away
because these photos pretty much
confirmed that he will indeed be Ronan
as we can see here in these bottom three
squares on the Left we have Hawkeye with
his bow in the middle we have Hawkeye
with the sword which would mean he is
Ronan in this picture and then on the
right we have Hawkeye in the top picture
and Ronan in the bottom two pictures so
this really does confirm that Hawkeye
will become Ronan in Avengers 4 so I'm
wondering what sort of tragedy will
cause him to become Ronin and I love
this photo right here again it's a
little blurry but I think it reveals the
most that we've ever seen about Ronan in
Avengers 4 it's interesting that he's
only carrying one sword ronan in the
comics usually has two but again they
can change whatever they want and he
could always have two and
movie so there it is brand-new leaked
photos for Avengers for what did you all
think I thought they were awesome I
thought they'd definitely give us a
better glimpse into what we can expect
for a vendor's for and I think now that
we have the first official trailer for
Captain Marvel we're gonna start seeing
more about Avengers force so I'm super
excited about that
so hit me with your thoughts about these
new leaked photos in the comments below
and again if you'd like to enter the
giveaway all you have to do is be
subscribed to my channel like this video
and comment below with your thoughts and
your favorite superhero thank you all so
much for watching woof woof
[Music]